- Today on BuzzFeed we're
gonna be talking about snails,
more specifically snail facials.
- The things I do for
this freaking company.
- Oh fuck.
- Remember me when this is over.
- Fuck.
- Snails used for snail
facials are garden snails.
They are called Helix Aspersa.
- We're gonna get snails put on our face
for some reason.
- I'm excited I guess to
see what it does to my skin.
- Yeah, I'm down for anything on the face.
That sounds dirtier than it
meant to be, but anything--
- Anything, she's down for anything.
- I'm really nervous,
my hands are literally
sweating right now.
- We're gonna get licked by little snails.
- Yeah, so I'm looking forward to that.
Be a bunch of little kisses.
- All right, woo.
- Are you having like a giggle fit?
You know I should tell you that insects
do not like large vibrations,
like the vibrations
from your mouth.
(screaming and giggling)
- The first one's on.
- This snail recently finished having sex.
As you can see it's appended,
it's like penis is still out.
So since we have such
a fun history together,
you get the penis snail.
- Great.
- [Diana] You get the snail
that still has a hard on.
- That's exactly how I
thought this would go.
- Oh my God, okay.
Oh my God.
- We often also put
snails on the decolletage
or the chest, because it is
very healing for sunburns
and stuff like that.
Are you okay, Jenna?
- I'm fine.
- [Diana] Are you sure?
- What the hell is the point of this?
- Believe it or not, snail enzyme facials
are all the rage in Asia.
(moaning)
Also, shhh, shhh!
You know, you would be
dead in a horror movie,
you know that, right?
- I feel like they are biting me.
Is that--
They are not biting you,
everybody thinks that.
- Ow!
- Fucking hurting you.
- The foot, the muscle on
the bottom of their feet
is kind of rough.
(giggling)
I keep misting these ladies
because we have to provide
our snails with a warm, wet surface.
(playful jazz music)
- My face feels like it just
had a bunch of sludge on it.
- How do I fell after that?
How could you feel after that?
- I wasn't crazy about this.
- I'm gonna cry.
- I gotta say my skin does
feel a little refreshed.
- My face definitely feels tighter.
Like almost after you
do one of those masks
that you but at the drug store.
- Sure.
- [Diana] Here, here.
Let me sit.
- Would I do it again?
Umm.
- (mumbles) miss Diane,
we got a business up.
- If I had really great results,
no matter how weird it is,
I'd probably do it again.
- There's butterflies in this room.
- What's happening?
- Maybe it's just not for me.
It's just not for me.
- Are we dreaming?
- What's happening?
- Why don't you just cut?
It's ended here.
- Stop this video right now.